two things before we get started today
one there are weird pronunciations in
this one I'm looking them up when I can
I have a laptop right here
sometimes it doesn't exist sometimes
there just aren't the pronunciations
available I'm doing my best but have a
go me in the comments if you want second
thing this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace
check out Squarespace comm for a free
trial find a link below
alright so for three years and eight
months Pol Pot ruled over Cambodia with
an iron fist the legacy that he left is
horrific millions of families were torn
apart hundreds of thousands were
terribly tortured and 1.7 million of his
own people were put to death so how did
it end this way well in this week's
biographic s-- we attempt to seek
answers as we delve into the life of Pol
Pot
[Music]
the man knew the world would come to
know his Pol Pot was borned Saloth SAR
on January the 25th 1925 in the small
village of prax above in Cambodia his
was a peasant family and from an early
age he found himself working long hours
in the rice fields the Salaf clan were
better off than many being landowners
who worked their own rice fields Tsar's
father loth owns nine hectares and would
employ local workers at harvest time his
mother sock nem was a devoutly religious
woman who brought up her children as
Theravada Buddhists saw was the second
to youngest of nine children however
three of them died early according to
his brother nap Tsar was a considerate
kind and hardworking child during the
day he and his brothers would work in
the fields then play in the rivers and
on the outskirts of the jungle in the
evening they would gather around an open
fire and sing the teachings and
histories of a local religious leader
for the vast majority of rural
Cambodians life revolved around the rice
fields in the village if you ever
traveled beyond the borders of their
birthplace however loft wanted his sons
to experience more from life so when he
was six tsar and his older brother were
sent to the cambodian capital but on pen
loth had a cousin by the name of meek
who was employed as a consort to the
king of Cambodians the boys were sent to
live with him no longer considered as
peasants Tsar and his brother were now
among the privileged as such they were
educated by the French colonial rulers
in a school where the teaching was done
in the French language Tsar studied a
French literature and history filling
his head with the events of the 1789
French Revolution and the reign of
terror that followed under the
orchestration of maximilien robespierre
former schoolmates rather that saw was a
quiet introspective young man who kept
his thoughts to himself he was an
average student at best apparently being
held back two years most of his
classmates were the children of French
officials or Catholic Vietnamese
Cambodia was officially a monarchy but
the king he ruled in name only with the
real power lying with the French
colonial government at this time the
French were tied up in a bitter struggle
to hold on to their power in neighboring
Vietnam there the communist army under
Ho Chi Minh was leading the struggle for
independence
the Vietnamese revolutionaries had
started to Train small groups of
Cambodians and infused them with the
desire for independence from this
European rule this was a movement that
was spreading throughout all of
Indochina at this time at the age of 20
Sur traveled with some friends on a
pilgrimage to the famous temples at
Angkor Wat this site was the rallying
point for Cambodian nationalistic pride
the trip left a lasting impression on
the young man in 1977 he stated if our
people could build an co-wash they could
do anything
we must revive on national soul and
pride in order to defend the nation
builds the country well and preserve it
forever the trip marked the awakening of
SARS political consciousness and his
drive for independence in 1947 he passed
the exams and gained entrance into the
CC sawara Secondary College and pnom pen
the following year he failed the entry
exam into the upper classes and he had
to leave the school with his academic
career seemingly at a standstill he
began to study carpentry then in 1949 he
won a scholarship to study at an elite
engineering school in Paris
[Music]
for the first few months he indulged in
the excesses that Parisian social life
had to offer but things changed when he
came into contact with some fellow
Cambodians who had views that built upon
the spark of nationalist pride that had
been ignited at ankor wat the great
began meeting at Tsar's apartment and
discussions soon led to the formation of
two groups one who advocated working
peacefully towards independence from the
French and the other who were in favor
of armed resistance from the very start
Saab was in the latter camp he and his
like-minded friends they pointed to
other countries around the world where
armed overthrow was working and they
noticed they all had one thing in common
the rebels were all communists there was
a vibrant communist movement in Paris at
the time and sirens those of his group
who worked for armed rebellion began
attending meetings saw began studying
the teachings of Karl Marx but found
them difficult to understand
however he readily cottoned on to the
writings of Joseph Stalin and became a
lifelong advocate of Stalinism with his
emphasis on rapid industrialization
totalitarian government and the cult of
personality in 1951 he joined the
Communist Party and by the time that he
returned to Cambodia in 1953 he had
committed himself to the cause of the
Cambodian Revolution once back on
Cambodian soil sir journeyed north to
join up with cambodian forces who had
attached themselves to the Vietnamese
communists in their fight for
independence from the French he now
lived in the jungle as a prospective
guerrilla fighter but first he had to do
an apprenticeship for the first few
months its duties consisted of
maintaining the group's vegetable patch
he later recalled most everyone there
was Vietnamese there were very few
Cambodians for a long time there was
nothing for me to do after a while they
let me work in the kitchen but really
the Cambodians were there in name only
[Music]
victory was achieved by Vietnamese
communists in 1953 following the French
disaster at the Battle of Dien Bien Phu
the French pulled out of not a severe
Nam but Cambodia also however the new
nationalist Cambodian government was
headed not by a communist by the King
Norodom Sihanouk still the top third of
Cambodia was under the control of Viet
Minh
sarens other local communists urged the
Viet Minh to continue pushing south
until the entire country was communist
but the leadership of the Viet Minh
resisted their surgeons a truce was
arranged with the king sir now return to
/ phnom penh where he continued to work
for the political Underground's his day
job was as a school teacher where he
taught history by night however he
worked to establish contacts with every
strata of society from intellectuals to
peasants in order to garner support for
the coming communist revolution around
this time sir met the man who would
become his closest political associate
and second-in-command nuan chair chair
later recalled that sir had an innate
ability to charm people and bring them
into the party having the ability to
explain things in a way that simple
people were able to understand sir also
met up with a revolutionary students who
he had worked with in Paris by the name
of King van sack together they worked on
plans for the country's first free and
open political elections sir winter vans
ax house for breakfast every morning to
work on their party's manifesto however
their work did not come to fruition king
sia nukid renounced his throne and
formed his own political party the
sangkum he threw his hat into the 1955
general election and won becoming
Cambodia's new prime minister see anouk
had achieved this victory though by
throwing his political rivals into
prison for serb the sham election marked
the end of any hopes he may have had for
a democratic means to bring about change
in his country he confirmed his
commitment to violent overthrow and
threw himself towards working toward
that goal in july of nineteen fifty-six
sir married a fellow communist party
member by the name of coupon re like sir
she had been educated in france and was
equally committed to the revolutionary
cause they soon became the power couple
of the under
and communist movement life was
increasingly dangerous for the
Communists under the rule of C Anouk he
had outlawed the Communist Party and
given them a new name the Khaimah Rouge
the pace of imprisonments killings and
general terror was stepped up as the
Prime Minister sought to stamp out any
and all opposition to his rule the
Communist Party secretary a close friend
of Sir was taken to the outskirts have
been on pen and killed is during this
climate of fear that sir accepted the
leadership of the Khmer Rouge it was
constantly followed by the police who
knew who he was but not his position in
the party by 1963 things had gotten too
hot for sir in the capital city and he
left to dwell in the jungle in the north
here he was taken in by the Viet Minh
who had set up camps on the Vietnam
Cambodia border they were now focused on
a new enemy within their country that's
of course the United States from there
Cambodian bases they would regularly
travel into Vietnam to make lightning
strikes before retreating back over the
border in response the Americans dropped
hundreds of thousands of tons of bombs
in North Cambodia in an attempt to kill
the Viet Minh in the process they killed
over the course of the war nearly a
hundred and fifty thousand Cambodians
the American bombing had the effect of
drawing more and more people to the Chi
LaRue's and soon served no longer had to
rely only on the Viet Minh he now had
his own guerrilla camps stretched out
along the border and he himself he had
transformed himself in the mould of his
hero Joseph Stalin he was the
unquestioned party leader and he now
went by the name Pol Pot he lived apart
from the rank-and-file of his army and
only allowed a select few the privilege
of having an audience with him Paul
believed that the lifeblood of his
revolutionary forces would come from the
peasantry but he also believed that they
needed to be molded so their sole
allegiance was to the party new recruits
would undergo an intense period of
initiation where they would be locked in
a Cell until they were proven to be
obedient Paul instead uses a rigid
disciplinary structure which included
group meetings where members had to
confess their weaknesses and seek
forgiveness
[Music]
in 1970 Prime Minister C Anouk was
overthrown by a military dictatorship he
escaped to the north and sought to
establish an alliance with his former
enemy the Khmer Rouge bolstered by the
supporters of C Anouk the Khmer Rouge
numbers rose by 64,000 by the spring of
1964 many of them were now armed with
Chinese supplied rifles Pol Pot's army
had gradually filtered down from the
border area and now controlled
two-thirds of Cambodia by December of
1974 Pol felt in a strong enough
position to make an assault on the
capital the crime Eruzione circle /
Phnom Penh and began to close in those
who could fled the city as the streets
became war zones within five days the
military government was overpowered and
the revolution was over April the 17th
1975 was day zero in the life of a new
Cambodia Cambodia was now called
Kampuchea and it was under the control
of its Stalinist leader Pol Pot now just
before we get into the really really
dark part of this video Pol Pot's reign
of terror I do want to thank today's
sponsor
I know ads in the middle of these videos
are a little bit disruptive but these
sorts of videos I think they're
important to make and they would be
impossible without our sponsors so I
really do hope in exchange for this long
video about the life of Pol Pot you
won't mind a quick word from the
fantastic Squarespace if you've got an
important message to share you can do it
with Squarespace or maybe you like me
and you need a place on the web for
people to find you or maybe you're
starting a new business and you need to
set up a website for an online presence
or a store well you should do all of
that with Squarespace and with
Squarespace it all starts with a
stunning template they really are super
good looking or if you hate their
beautiful templates I promise you're
won't you can start from scratch and
make your own
Squarespace make it all super-easy to
make something that looks amazing
furthermore you can easily move over an
existing domain and if you've hosted
websites anywhere else just move over to
Squarespace it's easy to do and then
everything after that point is just a
lot easier with Squarespace there's no
patches there's no updates there's no
tech crap that you have to deal with all
the time no one likes any of that
further Squarespace does have 24/7
support before making this out I went on
and I tried it to see if I could reach
someone just randomly and absolutely
could solid support it just works
look whatever you need a website for
whether it's for yourself or a business
Squarespace is the place to do it head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace calm /bi graphics and you'll
get 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain thanks again to
Squarespace for sponsoring check them
out through the link below and now let's
get back to the misery that is Pol Pot
[Music]
the people of pen on pen they
enthusiastically welcomes the Khmer
Rouge but their smiles turned to alarmed
the ruthlessness of pols men they shot
any military forces on site then Paul
ordered a mass evacuation of the capital
the reason given was that the Americans
were about to bomb pnom then guy Maria's
soldiers went into the city forcing
people out of hospitals and their homes
many died in the streets in the melee
that followed the reality was that there
was no threat of an American air raid
Pol Pot's simply wanted to get the
people out of the way so that he could
concentrate on rebuilding his new
society he told his aides that they must
use cutting-edge violence in order to
build a socialist system from the ground
up the 2 million people who were forced
out of a Phnom Penh had to pass through
Khmer Rouge checkpoints on the outskirts
of the city there they were assigned to
districts for re-education as field
laborers the policy of equality was
strictly enforced with any possessions
that set city folk apart from the
peasantry being taken off them Khmer
Rouge soldiers went through the now
deserted capital and destroyed any of
the trappings of modern civilization
that they could find any people who were
found to be hiding were taken into the
street and shot under Pol Pot's regime
communist equality meant that everyone
was to be a peasant as a result all of
the modern advances of the last 100
years they were rejected and even though
former city dwellers and peasants were
now working in the fields side by side
their Chi Minh rouge overseers held a
special hatred for the former urbanites
who were considered to be capitalists
they were given only half of the food
rations of the peasants the Equality
policy included children he had to live
with Khmer Rouge teachers from the age
of 7 onwards private thoughts and
feelings were considered to be evil with
uniformity the only acceptable way of
life the state would choose which people
got married and anyone who was suspected
of falling in love out
this arrangements were beaten to death
in public the khaimah rouge regime
outlawed any form of entertainment
including sports with former sports
fields and basketball courts being
planted as rice fields the feeling of
terror that had been generated reached
into the astral anse of power with
members of Paul's government's eager to
prove that they too were peasants and
they worked in the fields as a result
there was no real government Paul
instituted a rice harvesting quota on
the people which was three tons of
unhusked rice per hectare but less than
a third of this was actually being
produced meanwhile the people were
suffering physically disease was rife
and millions suffer from malnutrition
hundreds of people were dying every
single day Paul blames the lack of
success of his great vision on
infiltrators and enemies of the party he
devised a great purge to weed out those
non conformists a state secret
interrogation center was set up to
imprison and torture those who were
expected of being traitors the families
of those arrested would also be taken to
the prison and tortured if a child was
too young to be interrogated it would be
taken away and simply killed immediately
any adults who survived their torture
were taken out to the killing fields and
beaten to death of the 14 thousand
prisoners who passed through the gates
of the main interrogation Center in
Panem pen only seven survived many of
those killed were loyal Khmer Rouge
supporters who were falsely accused of
treason Pol Pot's had succeeded in
imposing his ruthless iron-fisted
control within the borders of Cambodia
but there was a new threat to his regime
just over the border
the Vietnamese having seen off the
Americans now turned their attention on
Cambodia a border dispute threatened to
bring these two countries to war as the
tensions were rising Pollard of his
latest purge right on the border zone he
suspected his defensive forces in that
area of colluding with the Vietnamese
after being viciously interrogated more
than a hundred thousand soldiers and
party officials along with their wives
and their children were executed as a
result of this wholesale massacre of his
own defense forces po left his eastern
border with Vietnam opened to invasion
and that invasion came on Christmas Day
1978 taking just 13 days for the capital
of the Phnom Penh to fall Pol Pot
managed to slip away and escape into the
Jang
but at least his three-and-a-half year
reign of terror was over in total it had
cost the lives of nearly two million
people the Khmer Rouge may have been
over at the party persisted for nearly
twenty years a remnant continued to wage
guerrilla warfare from its jungle bases
Pol Pot set up a base near the Thai
border and rebuilt his military force
with the aid of the Chinese and Thai
governments meanwhile the Vietnamese had
installed a new government made up of
Khmer Rouge supporters who had escaped
Paul's purges from his base in the
northern part of the country Paul gave
occasional interviews to reporters in
which he would invariably accuse those
who opposed him of being traitors in
1985 it was announced that he was
retiring from the leadership of the
Khmer Rouge shortly thereafter the
Vietnamese clamped down on the Khmer
Rouge moving into their stronghold and
decimating their bases Paul managed to
escape into Thailand where he remained
for the next few years in 1988 he went
to China to undergo treatment for cancer
the venom YZ withdrew from Cambodia in
1988 prompting Paul to return from
Thailand for the next eight years the
Khmer Rouge ran guerrilla operations
against government forces in 1996 the
government began engaging in peace
negotiations with individual Khmer Rouge
leaders leading many of them to defect
away from the organization meanwhile
Pollard suffered a stroke and was
paralyzed down the left side of his body
but this didn't stop him from handing
out death sentences when he heard that
his longtime right-hand man Sampson was
negotiating with the government he
ordered his arrest and execution
around this time 11 members of Paul's
family were also killed though it is
unclear whether he ordered those
killings on June the 19th 1997 pol was
arrested by the head of the Chi Minh
military who had had enough of his
murderous ways a show trial was
conducted for the ordering of the
execution of sun-sin and Paul was
confined to house arrest for the rest of
his life
[Music]
in his final years Paul had become an
avid listener to The Voice of America
radio show on the night of April the
17th 1998 he was surprised to hear that
the Khaimah Rouge had agreed to hand him
over to an international tribunal for
crimes against humanity later that night
he died him Abed Pol Pot's body was
requested by the Cambodian government
for inspection however he was cremated
by his followers before the government
could get their hands on it
this has led people to speculate that he
actually committed suicide rather than
being handed over to the court as a
result neither he nor anyone else has
ever faced justice for the horror of
Cambodia's killing fields so I'm not
going to ask whether you enjoyed that
video but I do hope you found it
informative and maybe brought this part
of history to light for you if you did
like it please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell if you do
want to hear about our videos just
hitting subscribe doesn't do what it
used to on YouTube so do hit that Bell
as well so you find out when we put out
new videos and if you're looking for
something else to watch right now why
not check out some other bios linked to
on the screen now and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]